traité de l'atlantique nord qui a donné
naissance à l'otan a été signé le 4
avril 1949 la création de l'otan visait
à l'époque trois objectifs contrer
l'expansion de l'union soviétique
empêcher la riche d'urgence du
nationalisme militaire pour la souris de
la deuxième guerre mondiale et
encourager l'intégration politique de
robbie vertu de ce traité une attaque
d'une puissance ennemie contrat que
l'otan est considérée comme une attaque
contre tous ses membres
au départ le temps en tête 12 membres
dont le canada les etats-unis la france
et le royaume uni
aujourd'hui 29 pays sont membres de
l'alliance dont de nombreux pays de
l'ancien bloc de l'est depuis la chute
du mur de berlin l'otan a mené des
opérations militaires dans plusieurs
régions entre autrement bosnie
herzégovine au kosovo en afghanistan et
en libye
le temps est la plus importante alliance
militaire du monde
les budgets consacrés à la défense de
ses membres correspondent à environ 70%
des dépenses militaires dans le monde